so if you want to start or grow a
YouTube channel this year then you're
going to want to watch until the end of
this deep dive training all about how to
get more views especially if you feel
struck stuck right now on YouTube or if
you want to start right and I'm actually
going to be joined by my friend Rob from
vid IQ today we're going to be going
through some multiple different YouTube
channels and all kinds of different
niches so I'm certain that what you're
going through your type of content will
be covered inside of this training and
there's going to be a lot of nuggets and
insights along the way in terms of how
do you get subscribers what's working on
YouTube right now and how can we improve
our videos our thumbnails the
optimization of our channels overall and
it's going to be super rich so smash
like if you're fired up to dive into it
I want to welcome Rob back to the think
media podcast Channel Rob how's it going
hey Sean and hello all think media
rights it's great to be here once again
Sean I love how you switch from one
camera to the other it is so seamless
and that's the next thing I want to
learn as a content Creator but really
looking forward to more Channel audits
I've already done two hours of it today
so I should have my auditing chops on
ready for another wave of
enthusiastic creators in their channels
well let's kick it off with Tiffany Lynn
and here we are on her Channel World
schooling family lifestyle and travel
Vlogs if we head over to the description
this is the go to channel for
discovering family friendly destinations
South Africa Western Cape of South
Africa expect lots of travel 62 000
views on her Channel overall no
Community tab post my heart just sunk
but there is an opportunity for anybody
with a community tab which is almost
everybody these days once you just set
it up in the back end
um we're posting a few shorts
we are posting
um many videos and we'll look at those
in just a second and as we tap into our
vid IQ tool eight uploads in the last
month 30 new subscribers 2609 views and
uh cool to see that Tiffany already has
some momentum and so what are some of
your initial Impressions Rob first of
all Tiffany congratulations on meeting
at least one Milestone of monetization 1
000 subscribers that is awesome to see
you are going to some what appear to be
spectacular places especially this pal
Rock apologies if I have mispronounced
that but that looks like an epic scene
there I am curious as to the
Montage style of thumbnails I like the
idea of almost having like that search
magnifying glasses of the thumbnails at
the top um Sean I was looking at which
give you the location and then four
different scenes from our location
for me personally it looks a little
cluttered but I know this Montage style
Works in certain niches such as uh halls
and Dollar Store holes and some beauty
style channels but to me it seems to be
reducing down the size of a potential uh
destinations that they're going to so
they look a little closer especially the
Africa burn one there's something in the
bottom left-hand corner of it but I
can't work out what it is is it animals
is it insects is it Bracken
because it's so small and this is even
even on a desktop thumbnail imagine how
it looks like on a mobile uh postage
stamp thumbnail it might be really
difficult to see but having said that
Sean I think there's a lot of Good
Foundations here they are sticking to
the value proposition of showing in uh
family destinations in South Africa so
yeah promising stuff here
yeah and so a big takeaway is simplifier
thumbnails and especially with these
shots too they're not even
cropped in shots they're wide shots on
their own and so to have a wide
landscape shot only given 25 percent of
the thumbnail could be challenging and
of course this deals with topic but the
most popular video on the channel has a
very simple background two clear
passports which is the desire of how to
get the dual citizenship a nice photo it
is it's applying the rule of three which
is three elements in this case the
passports would kind of be like one
element but technically there's
literally three things there's our
there's the individual and the two
passports
and some of these other best performing
again topics have a lot to do with it
but I think if you could simplify down
to your point this happy the Harvest
Festival I'm sure a lot of cool stuff
was happening there but just you there
with the one photo
um simplifies it and this home tour as
well just one amazing shot that doesn't
even actually show the home really you
assume you're viewing from The View but
that's a I think some clues of
simplifying the thumbnails let's um
preview out a little bit of the latest
video
hi you guys welcome back to my channel
and this is Tiffany in today's video I
want to share another unique experience
our family had about two weeks ago and
that's helping friends prepare for the
Africa bird
so I do think there's an opportunity
here to not open up with hi guys welcome
back to the channel I think you could
say that later but as far as the
structure of the hook I think we could
say
um
yeah you could start with the music you
could start with this Montage yeah
keep the music pumping I noticed you
made the music go down to highlight that
speaker's audio but I couldn't tell what
she was saying that was so you might
just tease you're giving a preview of
Coming Attractions or you might do a
voice over here and you're like the
Africa burn you know
it's this it's this and you want to
create some intrigue
part of
it yeah the mixing of the audio there as
you pull the music down
the on-camera audio could probably be
turned up I don't know if that's
necessary
good mixed music and good voice over
here would probably be my favorite
maybe make this a little bit shorter
with just a lot of quick hits
attached and then you go hi guys welcome
back and I guess we're now entering into
a kind of a vlog situation here so Rob
any thoughts on this content yeah I
would agree that the uh the opening
Montage was fresh and exciting it had
energy but as you say
it went on a little too long it felt
like sometimes you have to what's called
Kill Your Darlings and say this is a
cool 30 second Montage but actually to
keep the viewer engaged it needs to be
10 seconds long and then maybe I can
insert a little bit more of a montage a
little later on to you know keep
changing the pace of the video but I
think in terms of the footage that
they've
um recorded and how it was stitched
together was really promising from a
video perspective
yeah and the video editing skills here I
think with improving in video editing
and maybe the structure and the Order of
the storytelling is a big opportunity I
think one huge takeaway for today and if
you're watching live smash like drop an
aha moment that you want to apply to
your channel but Kill Your Darlings we
can fall in love with our own projects
but sometimes just because we're having
fun with the footage what is going to be
most effective and to your point a
30-second Montage versus a 10 second
Montage it forces us to make the shorter
Montage stronger like
um uh one of the Wu-Tang clan members
once said make it half short and twice
strong and so great Channel there by the
way today's episode is brought to you by
vid IQ and there's an exciting new tool
that vidiq has we're going to share that
later but you can actually get a 30-day
trial of niq's paid plan for just one
dollar at vidiq.com forward slash think
and uh Rob is going to keep he's gonna
drop some more wisdom a little bit late
later on this let's dive into our next
Channel which is Ashley NV social media
strategies
marketing social media growth YouTube
strategies subscribe for tick tock
Instagram and YouTube tips free training
courses email address weekly videos
Ashley
volarez mentor and marketing coach and
we have a
five new subscribers 13 uploads 2400
views and we are posting some YouTube
shorts over here let's actually check
this out I'm struggling to get leads
check out these simple yet effective
ways to start generating leads and
getting them contacting you like many I
to me I feel like this could be a little
quiet I can't adjust the volume of this
in my group I could be wrong the number
one agent in there
as a new agent but on desktop yeah and I
think on mobile you could just adjust in
both cases I think you just adjust your
overall audio but I can't actually mix
this audio that
I could be wrong let me compare this to
one of your videos are you
maybe it's about the same
okay cool good energy we're gonna Circle
back to that so Rob what are your
thoughts
so this is a channel that's I guess in
its Essence relatively similar to ours
um Sean and they're trying to help
um people increase their influence
income and impacts I I think that was
the um the same from video influencers
right that was the three eyes from what
I remember you're right and one thing I
might notice a lot heavy heavy real
estate there's a lot of how to get leads
in real estate okay and heavy I think
heavy in marketing because while we
serve a lot of creators yeah I think
we're looking at probably business
owners in fact she's exp which is a her
group is exp which is a a real estate
um kind of kind of like Keller Williams
which is also kind of a network
marketing model at some level if I
understand it properly so so she's it
would seem teaching generally social
media and marketing but with an emphasis
maybe in what she's doing inside of exp
because they've become one of the top
groups at exp which is a massive
movement so back to you so I think the
channel Banner if that is true should be
a little more explicit in that it may be
focusing on realist Realty in a social
media marketing world uh thumbnail wise
uh I think they're a solid start
I would like to see a bit more of a um
contrast between foreground and
background because it looks as if a
background but she's I think
dropping herself in is flat so we don't
get that nice contrast like my eyes
tracking the the seat and the monitor in
the background as well as her lower
resolution cutouts at the front
um another thing to consider as well
here is uh credibility so this channel
currently has I think what was it under
100 subscribers I'm trying to remember
that under 100 subscribers and they are
trying to help other
um people on YouTube to build their
reach and I don't know if they have the
credibility to do that in the sense that
you must follow these ideas uh when I'm
a smaller Channel having said that the
view counts look quite encouraging they
are several hundred for the subscriber
size of 100. so I'm just wondering if
one of the series is they may like to do
on their channel is their own journey of
growth on YouTube so what they learned
when they hit their first 50 subscribers
in their first 100 subscribers so it's
almost as if
somebody watching their content is
following them on the journey as well
but I'd love to know your thoughts about
that Sean I I I'm kind of second
guessing myself now I'm wondering is it
right to judge the Creator just on a
subscriber size but it is about growing
the influence on a social media platform
I think what you're making it a great
Point credibility is a is a big deal if
you're going to position yourself as a
marketing expert I think the opportunity
here for Ashley though is especially
when I look at our most popular videos
is for example
she did a Facebook ad that got 586
clicks to get real estate online leads
so it would seem her expertise would
probably be more in marketing and maybe
based on the channel Less in YouTube
strategies she's leveraging YouTube but
she's dropping case studies of stuff
she's doing elsewhere so I think honing
in your expertise if it was to say like
proven strategies for helping you get
leads and customers and and to your
point about niching down
perhaps in real estate alone like the
number one source to help you get leads
because here's free video editors for
realtors that's a practical tip all the
top videos even Instagram and she's
getting clients off Instagram it would
seem it would seem that YouTube itself
and then over time should you be
building that up and she's got a couple
new videos even with these levels of
views I'm sure that done properly
it's not about the size of the channel
because that the metric of success for
the creators the size of the channel the
metric of success for the business owner
would be leads customers transactions so
to your point honing in your expertise
so she's standing on more credibility
that'd be one two I would love to see
like 80 of the words eliminated from
everywhere from from the banner eighty
percent less words from the thumbnails
less words
um I think especially when it's there's
just a lot of words it kind of almost
feels like a lot of clutter
and I think that simplifying things that
you don't need to Echo the title and the
thumbnail best free video editors for
real editors it says best free video
editors for real estate agents so it
literally could be just you and a
picture of the four logos you could be
much larger in the four logos that
you're recommending of video editors
within that and then one thing that I
want to hit on is
I wanna for you
to get you more clients
right and your freedom to have your you
I don't know how much of your own unique
Vibe your goal is and I will of how this
is set up but
this is in my opinion too dark black
shirt on black background darker hair
you disappear
Ed you could probably really pop if you
had a hair light
um and you could search that later which
would then at least outline you make you
more distinct
and then it could be camera settings as
well as just lighting Source but like to
be honest if I'm spitting in and we
always are you know
as coaches
unless your Vibe is to go more kind of
like goth this looks like a
like a mystery crime show review
lighting or like a a horror film review
kind of lighting it's not super inviting
and lighting Dynamics can have a lot to
do with retention now again
really quick tips I really do think that
lighting and set are there's some
distinctions here there's CL like that
can make this pop a lot more make it a
little bit more visually appealing and
then similarly some of the photography
for the thumbnails because the lighting
on you is flat this is a little bit
better and I think
even just the lipstick color there a
little bit more color the larger shot
there some of these other shots kind of
have a flat
uh coolerness to them so warming it up
brightening it up
if that's on brand for you that can
absolutely lead to are you struggling
because as a communicator
it seems like you're an incredibly good
communicator you're very clear with
video marketing and not seeing success
good hook around because I'm gonna go
over some mistakes not to make that you
may be making the framing is a little
off for me as well Sean like that what's
happening in the top third of the um of
the frame why why are you kind of like
down here it feels a little odd that's a
great Point yeah you're you were just
doing that you're you're a little bit
down in into the and off to the side for
for me it would be similar like my goal
in kind of a perfect Center frame a
little bit closer to the top of the
frame here if I was over
if I was down here this might be a
little bit of a stranger Framing and so
um just a few small tweaks that I think
you can make there that
um you're clearly
uh smart and get great results at at
Marketing in these different areas and
and I think that would be a big takeaway
that I'd recommend for everybody
you know Ashley here is already getting
some great results her Channel hasn't
really blown up but she seems to be
getting results on Facebook ads and
other places lean into your strength and
one of the things we've been talking
about as we've been doing this Challenge
and everything is like it's really not
uh the measure of Success is Not
virality or subscribers necessarily
depending on what your business model is
so if you're in one of the top exp
agents and I looked it up I think
there's like they do like three percent
of all the real estate transactions in
America or something so leaning into
that genius Zone
um I think one of the things that makes
us afraid is
uh
uh niching down too much or being too in
too narrow of a niche or wanting to go
more broad or thinking I could help
people with marketing in general but you
don't want to be a Wandering generality
you want to be a meaningful specific so
you probably could be one of the top
marketers video marketer experts for exp
you could go even deeper there and then
if and to your point I would maybe
eliminate the YouTube strategies and
talk and then you could even go result
like results like online marketing tips
for getting more leads and customers in
your real estate business
you just became so clear and become like
the number one and already it would seem
that your business is doing good uh or
you know you've got these other income
flows so your measurement of success is
in a silver play button it is just more
of the right people you know following
your course and in your content and you
know as a reminder
uh as you all know we just for a limited
time open the doors to uh vrafam.com and
our YouTube Niche Finder course is a
deep dive course about getting this
right that is a big deal as far as uh
branding positioning business model
and the mistake a lot of people make is
only trying to again get a bunch of
subscribers and maybe going more broad
appeal I don't know if you feel like it
does feel that Rob was kind of
addressing that like you're kind of
going a little bit more broad appeal
maybe maybe afraid to Niche down I
actually think there'd be a lot of power
in uh niching down as it pertains to
that so as a reminder check that out and
of course we've got all of that in the
description down below
next up Rob is simple smoothie excited
about different channels different types
of topics smash like if you're learning
something today
14 subscribers 12 videos I want to make
one point right up front as I was
looking at this
um brand new channel
joined May well channel has been out
since 2013 but newer videos it looks
like just shorts I believe just shorts
so just started posting but here's
what's kind of interesting about YouTube
shorts with only 14 subscribers we have
had as many as 1 200 views nice very
nice so
and also smoothies very passionate topic
interested topic the algorithm can
understand it clear title pineapple
banana smoothie Bowl so kind of cool to
see with a total of
11 total shorts so far in simple
smoothie what are your thoughts Rob
as you say Sean to be hitting triple
digits on all videos right out of the
gate is fantastic I would not worry
about the subscribers uh for the for the
time being the subscribers will come and
obviously with the somewhat enormous
challenge of hitting 10 million shots
views in three months for monetization
that's not something to to worry about
right now just having this reach already
and the consistency like you started
with 50 views and then incrementally
every is this most popular or yeah okay
so it's most popular but
um like yeah every single video seems to
be getting 400 views or above which is
really strong and consistent what I am
seeing is a simplistic approach to
titles which are literally the flavor of
this movie not even how to not how long
it's going to take not how much it costs
anything it is literally at the flavor
of this movie with some hashtags I don't
know if that is the right strategy in a
long term to create Intrigue in the um
videos we probably need to watch one of
the shots to really see what's going on
is it literally just a how-to on how to
make it or is there something visually
satisfying okay
so they're taking advantage of YouTubes
that are off the popular music hopefully
we're all right yeah and take advantage
of YouTube's music options so whether
they can take popular music and put it
in their own shots I think that's a good
approach uh that would mean that there's
no voice over
um I don't know could you add some more
uh burning captions to help
um with the um with the story or the the
tutorial here
um but as as I say Sean like well what
we're 10 videos into this Creator's
journey and there are they're also a
great start
yeah so this is all I'm not going to
turn the audio on because this is all
popular songs basically no voice
the the text on screen is the title of
what it is I was wondering how they got
the text on screen and all the
thumbnails and the reason why is because
they just leave it up the entire time
because you can't select a custom
thumbnail so
um whether that's good or bad it is nice
because I'm like oh I'd love to have the
promise of the video text on the actual
thumbnail
um and I agree with that I think there's
three massive uh takeaways you can get
from this
um and one is powering up the titles and
topics how could you be maybe a little
bit more unique and so just echoing Rob
um under three minutes or super simple
or with some kind of random ingredient a
little more clarity it also could be
themed I think if you did you started
thinking about Trends that's how you
could go viral you could think about
themes of the year if it was a fall
smoothie and it had kind of a a leaves
around it a spring smoothie you put some
flowers an Easter smoothies Easter
lilies around like it just might really
be shared because like oh that looks so
cool when you're at you ask yourself a
question with vertical video is this
shareable would this be easy to share
would this be broad appeal would there
be reach around this and then I would
agree voice over a lot more engaging if
you're like
so this healthy green smoothie and maybe
a little education on it it's like this
healthy green smoothie will fight
detoxification you know detox your body
give you more energy and ultimately it
tastes delicious what you're going to do
is you put in your pineapples
um such and such cups put in half a cup
of spinach I use Silk almond milk you
could use other almond milk blur it you
know blend it up with my ninja if you
actually are interested in checking out
this Ninja blender I've pinned a link in
the comments and I've also put it in the
description as well if you're if you
want to check it out I love it and it
makes a tasty green smoothie by the way
that was a little affiliate strategy on
short which I was talking to Kyle
Anderson on our team too there is we use
genius links and there's one of our
shorts that is driven an insane amount
of affiliate sales which is shocking to
me because it's kind of hard to get to
the description it is but it is well
friction yes it is possible
and so taking this video voice over you
know thinking through it and
you know one of the other things that
could be fascinating is based on your
workflow because if you're building this
out in the YouTube shorts Creator which
I imagine you are tying this music in
that's cool but based on your workflow
if you can
download the video or edit the video and
get it before the music is done like
this is how uh my workflow has been
these days is like I sometimes will
build out a reel in Instagram and I'll
get it to its final stage maybe with
Instagram's captions I've edited through
it if I've used the green screen feature
and I click save video
and then the video is on my phone no
music
then I use Instagrams feature to pick a
popular song and I post to real I fill
out the caption put the hashtags on
there or whatever
then I take that video that's on my
phone now edited with a caption overlaid
and no music and I take it over to
YouTube shorts I click Plus at the
bottom add a YouTube short and I connect
popular music and then my optimization
process is description pin comment then
I take it over to tick tock and I upload
it there and pick a thumbnail out on
Tick Tock one of the frames put the text
on screen type in the caption there and
I upload it as well and so if on your
workflow with vertical video
um you think through some of that stuff
it can be a big deal and and as a
reminder that's also why we just uh also
finished up our
um our YouTube shorts Master Class you
can just see it up here next to AI for
YouTube and that's like a two hour
training actually where we talk all
about not just YouTube shorts but we
also were talking all about vertical
video in general because when your
workflow is dialed in and when your
strategy is dialed in the opportunity
of posting on multiple different
platforms with your vertical video
assets because I you know you know that
Rob and I are in love with of course
YouTube that is your home base that's
where the long-term opportunity is
eventually long form content is
something we'd encourage you to get into
But ultimately when you think about
um
these assets maybe you start going viral
on Tick Tock maybe you start getting a
lot of reach on Instagram reels maybe
Facebook reels become interesting for
you and you're creating the assets
anyways a few tweaks in your workflow
can create that leverage for you
I just want to add a correction Sean you
can now
um choose a custom frame from a YouTube
short to act as your thumbnail that's if
you go through
um the mobile app on Android or iOS so
you film it you get to the video details
and then there's a pencil icon you can
literally go frame by frame and choose a
choose a custom thumbnail so they're
slowly rolling out more functionality to
shorts which is good to hear
so I I'm going to make sure based on
Rob's advice here that I'm going to go
in
I am updating my YouTube app it is
updated and I'm gonna I'll confirm last
time I checked it didn't work for me I
don't know if it's rolled out to
everybody and I'm clicking up is I'm
clicking up in the upper hand left like
will this open up with this and so we'll
see uh in fact Rob uh I realized what I
could do is I can go to create short
right now yeah we can and I can't
demonstration folks I'm gonna upload
this video that I did yesterday of my
son and I'm just going to call that good
enough and not add a sound I'm going to
go next this is the latest version of
the YouTube app
and there's a pencil icon there you go
there you go so okay great so on iOS we
can go custom frame which would also as
you're editing your very YouTube short
maybe you put text on the end that you
know is going to be on there maybe
there's not maybe you don't want text
um the old hack was literally like the
last frame or something was actually
like a photoshopped file and yeah I
don't even think that's actually
necessary but I do think the framing
maybe text
um that's an amazing Insight smash like
for Rob dropping the pencil YouTube
short thumbnail we are out here you
gotta just press on
think media podcast
and we're going through some of your
channels and today's stream is brought
to you by vid IQ
um Rob there is a new feature on vid IQ
and we've got a bunch of more channels
to go through a lot of more tactics to
share with y'all but I am so pumped
because vid IQ is one of the tools we
use every day here at think media uh
keyword research daily yesterday we were
going through daily ideas tool planning
out some of the niche specific videos
for our Channel and I was so inspired
because I was like man this is so fast
given us a lot of recommendations around
the Sony zbe10 which we not only have
videos in the past on that but that is a
hot camera and some angles on it so that
was just the daily ideas tool but
there's a new tool I'm going to share
your screen and break this down for us
yeah so as we all know AI is a big topic
of conversation we already have our AI
coach where you can just basically have
a conversation uh with a YouTube AI
coach and it will give you certain
suggestions on like how to grow your
channel do a Content schedule and such
but now we're taking that to the next
level with our AI content generator and
to find it you just go to vidiq.com
forward slash generate the best news is
right now it is completely free uh so
you can check it out and the reason for
that is because it's currently in beta
we're still testing out so we'd load
feedback on it and I'm describing this
as version 0.1 of the only YouTube Tool
you will ever need in the future so what
we have here is simple text bar and we
can type something in I'm just going to
use something very simple I'll try
crypto and what that should do is
generate in around about five to ten
seconds a intriguing click-worthy title
the future of cryptocurrency got a
comprehensive guide I'd say it's a
starting point from just a single word
that's not too bad we're already going
to provide you a description we're going
to give you you effective keywords that
you might want to use if you are still
interested in tagging your videos and
then perhaps some demonstrations of some
thumbnails now this is where sometimes
it does need a little bit of tweaking
because I don't know if those thumbnails
as backgrounds will be useful for
cryptocurrency but we were testing it
earlier on today and we tried Minecraft
and it was bringing very effective
Minecraft backgrounds that we could use
um so thumbnails do need a little bit of
work and we're not saying that you
should use these as your final
thumbnails these should be users
backgrounds you know blurry the image
something along those lines but on top
of that we are providing a video script
can you download those thumbnails you
certainly can yes I would just click on
this and then I could download the
thumbnail if I wanted to and then you
could throw that in canva or photoshop
or PicMonkey or something and then add
yourself to it or just go a little bit
deeper definitely definitely definitely
and also we do video scripts so we we've
got a video script you know this may be
your intro or it could be something for
a YouTube shot and it even provides a
voiceover of that script as I say all of
this is gonna Leap Forward
tremendously in the next three to six
months this is the worst version you're
seeing right now and already
for for a comprehensive tool that just
required one word to generate all of
this in 15 to 20 seconds I'm really
excited about it Sean and we're looking
to really work on this tool going
forward as part of our vid IQ tool set
which of course is free and then if you
want to try more of our tools uh there
is the um fantastic offer that um think
media have which I think is what 98 off
one dollar for 30 days
and so and then what is that URL again
for that for you vidiq.com forward slash
generate and it's completely free you
don't even need to log in to test it out
so we'd really appreciate appreciate
your feedback awesome so I'm dropping
that in the chat on the YouTube live
stream that iq.com forward slash
generate and uh
you can check that out right there on
screen as well super cool
um I'm gonna type in camera review
and I'm over here
the ultimate camera review everything
you need to know we got our tags we got
our description we got our thumbnail
background right there
we got another one coming oh that's
interesting yeah okay that's not too bad
is it
okay had a bit of text in uh some of the
negative space there
yeah maybe cut off this little like side
lens thing
um and and edit it a little but that's
yeah nice and crispy so that's cool what
a cool tool to play around with and so
again that's vidiq.com forward slash
generate that's entirely free and then
also uh if you want to check out the
30-day trial of it iq's paid plan with
all the cool features vidiq.com forward
slash think links in the show notes and
smash like if you're getting value this
is the think media podcast Channel my
name is Sean Cannell we are going
through channels from our video record
Academy group
um and we are if you're just joining
though there's going to be a lot of
insights to be asking how can you apply
this to your content what are some
things that you could do to get better
on your next upload or maybe some
mistakes that you're making on your
channel that you can learn from our next
Channel soft Landings UK which is a
travel consultancy we do not have a
channel Banner here
um so that's not just me scroll down
that's just a note
and so that is an opportunity to upload
one
Nigeria is where we're located appears
travel consultancy is the full
description so I think
you know one of the reasons why we
encourage filling out the description is
one
there's now a new 50 characters of text
or so that is sort of like the tagline
for your channel right underneath your
handle but two when you take the time to
actually fill out
your description and to sit down and
write who you are what's the promise of
your channel who's it for what can
people expect
the biggest power of doing that is
Clarity for yourself it's putting like
your ideas on paper your vision on paper
your goals on paper it's not that a lot
of people necessarily stop by the about
page although some could it's that the
clarity that you will gain from the
process will improve your channel in the
process
so
we've got full-length videos about
seven of them
and we're doing a lot more shorts
and let's check out one of these
five jobs to get as a student or new
arrival to the UK now for many of us
when we've just come into the UK job
searching is a really difficult task you
know you spend a lot of time going left
and right and the job
um I like the topic I think that this is
a good short it's clear it's a clear
promise what I don't love is this idea
of
for UK students and new arrivals full
video on YouTube
it's done is better than perfect I think
and and experimenting is always good but
one of the biggest mistakes I've noticed
I think you know people make with shorts
is thinking that their promotions or
commercials for other videos
the way I think you should use shorts is
they should be Standalone the chance of
even actually getting someone from a
short to another video the fact that
it's just so small it's like it's not
that it can't be done if there is a
full-length video you should pin it in
the comments you could put it in the
description you could try to do an end
card I don't know if they still allow
that but you can put an end card on
there but people's behavior in shorts is
typically that they want to stay in
shorts and they want to swipe through
there if a short grips them they go this
channel is interesting I want to dig
deeper into this Channel and they decide
to look into your like that's up to them
but
99 of the time I think using a short as
a commercial or just if it's cut out of
a video just make sure the content
stands alone and fully delivers value in
the short itself as opposed to is just
like a a commercial or a trailer my
opinion that is not how to use shorts
let's go to the here's the full video so
we could see the five jobs to get us
which as an asset I love the fact that
you're
chopping this video up my goal would
just be to say is there a 60-second
version where you just talk about like
security jobs and that is its own short
and you're able to efficiently edit that
down
um and and turn it into a short that
stands alone
uh I see that probably you're framing on
this was so that you could crop in which
is a kind of a cool idea maybe you shot
it in 4k
um It's the final outputs 1080p but that
allows you to crop in and gives you the
short editing later I think that is
smart it's a smart workflow to consider
security is such a huge cycle in the UK
and security is required for all very
practical good tips here and
um good production and 149 views
is is kind of cool to see so Rob what
are your thoughts
when I was um watching the short uh Sean
uh I was thinking about attention span
because uh viewers on shorts are
ruthless because all I need to do is you
demonstrate Sean is to say next next
next
and I think the title was top five jobs
in the UK and we were about 15 seconds
in and we hadn't got to any of her jobs
and so I'm thinking in the short no
Preamble just give me it straight away
number one number two number three
number four number five 25 seconds let's
move on to the next shot uh now
I had the disconnect of soft Landings UK
travel consultancy and the content until
I think the very first
sentences of the video itself which then
taught me ah this is for
um foreign
um
foreign visitors who are landing in UK
for the first time and looking to stay
there on a permanent basis and are
looking for jobs and how to establish
themselves so how do you turn that into
as you've used yourself Sean the term
North Star how do you turn that into
your North Star description for your
channel whichane can also become your
channel Banner
and then I was just looking at the uh
quality of a video as well I didn't see
any um b-roll uh from the brief parts of
the video that we saw about top five
jobs and I was just wondering how much
editing has gone into the content post
filming and I wasn't sure
because if it's just this person talking
into a camera at this point quite a bit
there's a zoom in there's an emoji so
that's a good point so you could pull a
ton of b-roll or still photos that are
animated to to actually illustrate food
delivery parcel temporary job apps
you're absolutely right this this could
100 benefit from b-roll go on
so yeah just looking at the time level
it looks as if it was two two camera uh
talking head and again viewers like
pattern interrupts something changing
whether it's sounds image and so on
the Creator looks confident in front of
camera I think they and they have a
knowledge man and they and they have a
very unique value proposition uh they're
probably one of only
few thousand people who've landed in the
UK and have this knowledge and
experience
and they're just one of maybe a dozen
people who are actually sharing their
knowledge and message on YouTube so I
think you should really tap into that
value proposition so that people can
easily find you when they're searching
for for Solutions on YouTube and they
you come up as one of the top search
results
yeah that's brilliant and
um I think that ultimately
um
all of your wisdom there related to
b-roll is one of the biggest things we
can learn from now this sounds intense
when it comes to editing but they
usually say you want to switch the frame
up every three seconds Max seven so kind
of three to seven seconds switching the
frame up could be as simple as this
would be a frame switch that's just kind
of a reset of attention perhaps in a
live stream like this it could be you
know putting something on the screen
which if it's like and hey by the way
you get a 30-day trial of vidiq's paid
plan maybe better than that though even
would be the tips and so when I'm doing
a live stream I like to sometimes if
I've got 10 tips I put the numbers up
and it gives some somebody something to
see we bring Rob up make them bigger or
smaller this would just be live
streaming kind of ways of resetting
attention but if you're editing you've
got the benefit of
especially in such a linear that you
could use story blocks or there's
probably free Creative Commons stuff
these days or unsplash.com to get
um you know even just some free
photos I mean I wonder food delivery so
there's other sites like free stock
photography and you can just animate
photos and so you could go like food
delivery just interesting thought I mean
that's unsplash plus so that's actually
going to cost you but let's see you know
that's that looks like food delivery in
the UK it's raining
yeah so yeah like you could you could
take this photo download it free for
commercial use or for your videos throw
that into your editor give it some
slight animation
um and there's this is just one example
and there's other things like that and
then there are some paid stock video
sites and so those things could
absolutely increase retention and I
don't I also want to encourage you to
not be overwhelmed
everybody watching this or if you're
here live or on the replay because
um I know three to seven second edits
learning editing can be overwhelming but
remember we're just getting one percent
better with every upload so
um if you could just get a little bit
more content a little bit more b-roll a
little bit more of camera angles
changing or
think cool things happening on the
screen
every upload we can get a little bit
better and then some days eventually our
goal here at think media podcast and
think media is to get you to the place
where you can maybe hire an editor if
that's not your passion it is actually
some people's passion
um and uh some great tips there all
right we've got Mr and Mrs Beefcake
coming up in just a second but people
were asking Sean how are you doing
Channel reviews and these are actually
coming from our VRA group so we're not
doing any open Channel reviews right now
we've got a bunch queued up
um they're from our private Facebook
group of our video reggae Academy
Community however I highly recommend uh
learning from all of the insights here
and we've been getting some great
feedback
um thank you Mrs lorda watching and
learning Rob and Sean are the best what
a great collaboration saltwater heart
Studio appreciates you being here and um
we're gonna keep it moving but if you've
already learned something
Gabriel saying great feedback one of our
favorite things is aha moments because
there's something about writing down the
insights that you're learning
Sharon I'm with others aha moments are
one of our favorite thing because my
question for you is what are you
applying to your channel so you can
improve your next video
next up is Mr and Mrs Beefcake smash
like if you're learning something today
we've got 15 uploads 22 new subscribers
14 000 views this is a weekly lifestyle
and entertainment videos
they
do weekly shorts and sneak peeks and
funny behind the scenes bloopers they
are in the United Kingdom
here are the shorts and our video topics
excuse me
are things like looks like eating food
yep eating food together
um testing out
a an electric toothbrush
trying doing a hot snot
kind of like
hot ones on their own they got a little
milk there a hot sauce challenge got
some wings or some chicken nuggets to
try those on
a lot of food stuff
air fryer unboxing
let's check out a little bit of this and
then we'll give our feedback what can I
do
I have got a solution
whoa
check this out out
wow
[Music]
so we did a thing I like that your
bumper was short hmm
logo Sting If any was like two seconds
we thought we'd jump on the height and
basically buy an air fryer because so
many
um
my production thoughts are are it would
I I'm guessing we're going on camera
audio and then the camera is on the
other side of the
what do you call the kitchen things you
call them a counter counter but what do
you call them in the middle the land the
Island an island I think the camera and
the tripod is on the other side of the
island
and so where we can kind of hear you
it's a little bit faint uh really quite
and these days
you know some of the options we have
is uh wireless mic DSLR
um and you can get these dual ones and
the ones that we've talked about on
think media
um
let me find this for you because yeah
here you go like something like these
there's cheaper ones than these but
with two of you you could go this plugs
into your mic Jack assuming you have a
mic Jack so that's obviously or there is
the one that's trrs that will plug into
your smartphone
and then there's two little clip-on mics
to have two guests or it'd be perfect
for you guys and so to the tune of 49.95
um you can invest in microphones like
this they're becoming much more common
and I'll drop a link for anybody that
wants to check that out but
Rob what is your thoughts on Mr and Mrs
Beefcake first of all full credit for
doing videos with your partner If Ever I
try to do anything with this
like with my wife we would fall out even
before the splash intro screen it just
it's just not going to work for us so uh
yeah gravity are doing something
together as a as a as a team
when I was looking at the content itself
uh Sean it looked as if it was a little
all over the place it felt like they
were creating content
for their own entertainment and
indulgment because we had some food
challenges we had some um makeup
um stuff you know what it almost feels
like they've gone through their
subscription list of all of their
favorite creators and for all this looks
cool this looks funny let's do this
ourselves on our Channel
and that would be great if you were a
well-established
um team with a big following who would
watch whatever type of content you're
going to be throwing out on YouTube but
in terms of a Content strategy for a
smaller Channel
you know we're going to use that term
again niching down might be a bit of an
idea here and also I'm looking at some
of the challenges and the reviews and
I'm thinking were those popular six
months ago 12 months ago are they still
popular now I'm not entirely sure
I think also if you are going to do
these challenges and reviews and I think
you mentioned in one of these that you
were jumping on the trend of air fries
that's fine uh what else could you do
that's really trending right now but
those are my first observations on the
channel Sean
um did you just saw my most popular
event and I've been on the channel I did
and and I think that that it just goes
deeper in what you're suggesting Rob we
could introduce some Channel confusion
here because I wouldn't be surprised
that this video is maybe still
generating some subscribers or some
awareness right yeah
and maybe not because I don't see any VP
Edge but there's vph but there could be
you've still got some of the biggest
videos on some
gymshark clothes looks like this stuff
did pretty good when you were doing the
fitness stuff physique update
and then some of these kind of cut in
but we definitely went a new Direction
now you may just be able to ignore these
if they're not causing you current
growth but one of the most painful pills
to swallow
for people that have had established
YouTube channels that they've
experimented a lot with as you know Rob
is if you have videos bringing you
awareness and subscribers and viewers
that aren't interested in your newest
content yeah probably make those private
or unlisted
and even though it's like oh but they're
actually getting me reaching they're
giving me growth the question is where
are you going now what kind of content
are you creating now just a thought and
um we are seeing you know a year ago we
had fiance reacts to Eastern European
food uh to to take a step back we have
so many though like Fitness videos that
seem to be the best videos mind you that
was the six or seven years time to
accumulate the views but I mean maybe it
got bored or all that to say is to take
a step back
I think we see what you're doing here
you know like we all can maybe see that
there are
this idea of entertainment YouTube
channels which they have stated that Rob
I mean that's the thing that they also
definitely yeah this is lifestyle and
entertainment videos
I think the problem with that is that's
it can be hard to break through and so
you want to just be aware of the
mountain you're climbing in the battle
you're fighting
you're going for
um
Mass Appeal
um you you have to you want to be
self-aware in terms of your charisma
levels your your humor levels uh your
ability to to think through some of that
stuff and then what I would argue too is
I think that the production value
Channel if you're new here like to give
you some hardcore coaching this tilted
angle
with the echoey audio we are Mr Mrs BK
today we are making them and with with
the opening shot that doesn't even
actually hook like if if this this
should open up
and
it should go like hello everyone it
should go
and there should be like Sweat Beads on
like someone's forehead and music should
be like
and then there should be some drama and
some tension between you and what is
this I mean this is just a it seems to
be a cooking video but you should be
there should be conflict you guys were
fighting over putting the ingredients in
in the wrong order
if it's entertainment if it's also just
a practical cooking video even still it
should hook
like showing the final product showing
some of the ingredients getting People
Pumped maybe cut out your intro
altogether and we're like today we're
cooking a the dream dessert it's a
gluten-free lactose free no bake lemon
cheesecake let's get into it and and
just get straight into it production
value editing sound quality
and you hear me say a lot that
you know it's the content value that
matters not the production value that's
based on the industry because we help so
many people that if your promise is
eight things not to say
when buying a home the person watching
that doesn't care about the production
value they just want the value of the
content but if you're saying I'm
planning my flag in entertainment
then
Netflix is entertainment Hulu is
entertainment I'm not saying you have to
go to that level but like lighting sound
editing music quality of the audio
what are you competing with you know I
think another opportunity that you would
have if we go deeper in this Rob is
reactions and uh reaction videos is just
a hot Niche it can be crowded but
there's just massive opportunity there
but if you look at the quality of the
best reaction channels
the cuts the quickness of it the it's
it's it's a pretty high level of editing
it's a pretty high level of and that
could all feel a little bit overwhelming
but all that to say is if you're
committed to going deep inside of this
um let's let's uh let's just check out
this what time is it you can't wear a
suit and a bow tie and scream at people
it makes me feel something I've never
felt before what do you think of when I
say Limp Biscuit a biscuit with a lint
so we have incredibly bright
colorful outfits good lighting blue
background quick editing stuff comes in
and and we're then we also reacting to
something that is Trend surfing and
influence surfing at a high level
um and then you have multiple guests and
whatnot so just as far as aspirational
wise
I two things as we land the plane in any
final thoughts Rob number one I would I
talk most of our creators out of this
because meanwhile there's a practical
path of kind of making like picking a
niche making kind of more search based
of course tapping into suggested doing
some affiliate marketing and earning an
extra one two three four five k a month
and like and writing off under the
sunset and maybe never being famous flip
side
is you guys go a whole another level and
you you say no entertainment is the
dream and we want to be like some of the
biggest entertainers you think about
branding marketing photography editing
quality set sound and you take one step
at a time but you lean into those things
to compete compete with the expectation
of other entertainment content out there
Rob thoughts
Sean when you saw my most popular on the
channel I did see one common thread of
recent videos and you touched on this
partner reacts to now it's Eastern
European food it's British snacks that
could be their guiding Flagship Series
so they can experiment with all of these
other types of videos but I think every
other video should be going back to this
root content which seems to work and
again is that TV tilted yeah I mean we
gotta get the shot level
we gotta hide the cords the radiator
looks like it's level the radio it looks
like it's level
so I think I think there's multiple
accesses off right now I think the TV
might it's either the TV's off or the
camera's slightly off or and then and
then the audio is just the on-camera
audio there's an echo everyone welcome
back to the channel yeah today's video
in this particular situation I'll link
up another video for you that uh
that could make this sound great is you
get a little boom pole this could be
very affordable
um you get a little boom pole a little
shotgun microphone a longer cable and
again we might be dealing with a no no
microphone Jack which by the way that's
going to be one of your Investments
would be maybe a camera
or you can always do an external audio
recorder and then you have to sync and
editing but uh
I think that
the two of you sitting down like that
um
let me see here
shotgun mic hack think media here we go
the 15 boom might hack now
hey my name is let's check this today
I'm going to show you how to set up your
shotgun microphone on a boom Pole to get
the best audio for your YouTube videos
let's get into it so that right there
see how it's you get the boom pole is
like 12 bucks the cable is like five
and that's it and then you plug it into
your shotgun microphone screwed on the
end and so
um I'll I'll share a link to this video
as Rob gives us final thoughts but
improving the audio here as possible one
other thing you're dealing with and I'm
empathetic it seems like you probably
have a square footage issue a lot of us
do because you're backed up against the
wall and and that could one thing that
can help with that is a wide angle lens
or some kind of a wide angle lens or
just being thoughtful about how you
arrange and set up your shots I know
I've talked about this multiple times
but like as we go through these things
that is actually what our video creation
Made Simple Workshop is all about so
that's the last time we're ever doing
that live where Nolan is like literally
everybody uh that joins is going to be
getting coached talking about how to set
up your shot how to uh take advantage of
of uh maximizing small rooms small
spaces and so so
uh it does look like they're kind of
editing in little meme
I think they were using two cameras just
I think yeah
so I think they need to do a bit more
that's that's cool the fact that they've
already got a multi-camera
system going on even I don't do that
really imagine that being like an
editing nightmare but to be doing that
already on content
and one of the things that about this
angle I agree I like the second angle
but I feel like more jump cuts a little
faster yeah more like during this time
some ultra big Zooms in like you zoom in
you you fast zoom into his squinty face
which is hilarious
you
do a sound effect email right there as
well
yeah that's really great thumbnail and
you maybe outline her you get her closer
but yeah you could have like fire coming
out of his head or electricity
and understanding this like that the
editing it would take
to maybe get some animated cartoons
around him or little gifts you put in
even on a basic beginner level it's
going to take a lot of time
but let's also think about the reward on
the other side you step into the next
level of caliber here and now we're
talking about ten thousand twenty five
thousand fifty thousand views now we're
talking about ad Revenue now we're
talking about brand deals and so just
with a big encouragement I know that was
a lot and and I appreciate you
submitting your channel for us to be
ruthless as you said Rob uh but we want
you and our whole Community to get
better and and some of those tools like
the microphone maybe being thoughtful
about the shot thoughtful about the
editing and really good unlock success
leaves Clues
and so good unlock seeing in some of
your popular videos the question for
everybody watching is what trends in
your popular videos could you double
down on and it is wife reacts wife
reacts fiance reacts and
like you said every other of those and
maybe getting that show format dialed in
um a little bit
we are dropping
we're we're at the top of the hour we're
going to be going a little bit longer we
have a few more channels to go here as a
reminder today's stream is brought to
you by vidiq.com forward slash think uh
check out the link in the description
down below a powerful Suite of tools for
helping you making better uh for helping
you make better data driven insights
better data driven decisions Rob just
like you I got up at 7am to do a podcast
with uh somebody in Singapore and that
was an hour and a half I did a coaching
call with like a one-on-one client
what else did I do and I'm here with you
I laid down my wife said are you sick I
said I'm tired and uh and now we're here
but I'm grateful and and nobody cares
about my pain or your pain Rob's been
rise and grind it's rise and grind man
uh get 30-day trial of it I use paid
plan for one dollar it's an awesome
Suite of tools check out the description
down below and uh super fired up for
that
um next up Rob is the watercolor
classroom
we have 7 000 subscribers 85 videos we
have
206 000 views you can paint yes you can
paint come learn how
I love the title yeah I like that
because it's very clear what it is and
it's clear that it's Becky and let's see
what's happening on our stats six
uploads 70 new subscribers
almost 5 000 views
she did a poll a year ago oh no
oh no
good though but let's get back to using
that Community tab because your last
poll was a year ago you could post in
the community tab once a day up to two
three times a day I think is fine and so
why not
um we do have some shorts and that's
exciting to see I like the aesthetic
you're great her own music
I'm gonna mute it though
wow
looks beautiful very talented yeah we'll
come back to that in a second and then
let's hit these uh let's hit the main
videos here
best wash brushes water control fixing
mistakes
and a whole series
on
classes three of eight that's an
interesting strategy with the same
thumbnail but it ties it all together
it's kind of like a free course building
out one result so that's interesting Rob
what are your thoughts
so in terms of this class what was it
eight lessons I just want to see the
view counts on these because it looked
like it was a situation of diminishing
returns out of the first couple of
videos got more views and then slightly
less as it progressively went on
I don't know Sean considering that some
of these videos are like three minutes
long seven minutes long
would it be better to put this into like
an hour-long uh video and the only
reason I asked that is because
typically speaking
on YouTube you want to get the whole
meal in one course as opposed to having
to watch it over
several weeks in this case I believe I
don't know if there are like
learnings at the end of it like it so
you're up to this point in in the video
and you'll be able to do this and master
it by next week and then we'll carry on
to the next lesson I mean again the the
art the artwork here is I mean is that
actually a drawing or a or a photograph
I think that's the photo and then that's
what they're working on right okay but
nevertheless like yeah it's wild
you know to kind of spin off your idea
here too and I don't think I've ever
shared this before in a context like
this so this is this could be a kind of
powerful opportunity I think what some
people do
is you be shocked when someone wants to
learn the depth of what you've learned
here
so Rob's point it probably would be more
effective to put out this first video
and then actually invite people to an
opt-in or even a paywall
if it ended up being 167 and let's cut
that number down to
let's just say 25 of 200 so what is that
50 I say 50 people saw the first video
and they were like oh this is cool I
would love to I would love to check you
know that out more
um and they get to self-select so it
doesn't fill the channel up rather than
give the videos away free if you will at
this size of Channel
you have 50 people that take this class
for
15 dollars
and you generate 750 dollars
for a lot of people in the crater
economy people that are trying to get
YouTube ad Revenue it's gonna take you a
long time to build up to that you're not
going to get anywhere near that off the
5 000 views a month you're getting but
yet I would I would believe that within
your community that wants to go deeper
the opportunity of learning deeper if
you will business skills or online
marketing and creating great videos
serving the people that want the free
content
but instead of because it's kind of in a
way what Rob said too it didn't even
perform very good
but you still could about the great
video which got 500 views
and it's a win-win-win-win-win some
people get some free content they get
started they can go in it's not
expensive people are going to pay that
all day long too if we shift our mindset
we go to this place in Las Vegas where
we paint pottery with our sun
um and now we we did like their
footprints on a Christmas ornament and
then they you know put it in the oven
and then we give it to Grandma my mom on
Christmas of my baby's Footprints how
cute is that you know we're people are
going to pay all day long for a 20
dollar
art class A 40 art class and so
um that may be a skill set to learn of
course to set that up what are you gonna
put it it could it could just be YouTube
channel memberships and you can have
exclusive content in back there as well
um it could be patreon or it could be
actually Packaging
some of that more advanced
um stuff and this is where I think
that a lot of people underestimate quote
unquote their small Channel now it does
have 7 000 subscribers but like not a
huge Channel how much potential income
earning opportunities there could be
existing right now if you're thinking
about it a little bit different what
else you thinking Rob
looking at the videos that followed on
from that series The View counts are
better so I think it does demonstrate
like a bit of viewer fatigue on that
series and you know again just
liberating a little bit more on the
point of a series
the Creator perhaps didn't know what to
do with the thumbnails either because
they were all identical with the
exception of the part number one to
eight so a viewer who's casually coming
across these videos maybe asking have I
already seen this video before or if
it's they're seeing part seven oh do I
have to watch the previous six parts of
this video to to follow along with
what's what's happening there
um so I think more videos that stand on
their own without having to be connected
in this way and I love the idea of um
you know I think those videos in total
would probably generated about 7.50 but
as you say if you're able to send them
from one video to a skillshare udemy and
generate 750 that would be um much
better now in terms of the video style
uh we've got the top down view I'm
guessing there's narration going on here
Sean any music or just narration looks
like just Generations okay
give it a video length it feels like
they're being clear and concise you know
you're going to learn how to do
something in less than four minutes a
drawing style that's pretty cool to me
as well
um I noticed they did shorts uh Sean I I
was wondering if they get more traffic
on their shorts because we saw that one
time lapse video which looks pretty cool
okay so consistent views but nothing
that's gone viral or is that the latest
video we're seeing there both the latest
and most popular is this filling in the
background one fair enough fair enough
yep and and yeah it's actually kind of
the same on both cases but I think
this is an inspiring channel in general
there's momentum there's history there's
consistency I think one of the
opportunities of small tweaks leads to
Giant Peaks I do want to hit saltwater
heart Studio asks can you pay wall
videos be done on YouTube or do we have
to go off platform
two things one you can do it with
Channel memberships so I believe on
channel memberships you basically can
have like a separate Community tab or
what you do on the community tab is
Select I only want my members to see
this you can have unlisted videos or
videos that you give them and not the
public
YouTube is also going to be creating
tools so that you can essentially have
your own paid to play content or kind of
kind of like online courses integrated
with YouTube platform warning warning
warning
these other features that YouTube does
they take 30 percent so man super chats
Channel memberships if you were to grow
up your
imagine your channel members to like six
figures a year because you really hustle
and you're in Creator economy you build
up momentum a thousand true fans
whatever and you really you get six
figures a year thirty percent they would
take thirty thousand dollars then you
pay taxes and everything else so
in my opinion there's better options I
do understand sometimes you know the
benefit is people don't have to leave
the platform it's integrated right there
but thirty percent is is gnarly and so
sometimes patreon's like five to ten uh
my friend Daryl's working on another
thing and there's other options out
there and then there's things where you
have a pay a monthly payment like a
kajabi or something where um
they don't take anything but you do have
the expense of paying for it monthly uh
we we have some cool options if you've
never seen thinkmediatools.com
um that's got some different things to
use but yeah you could certainly keep it
on YouTube but I don't really recommend
it
um great channel here though my favorite
thumbnails Rob are these latest ones I
like the lighting the daylight the color
the simple amount of words
I think the bird with all the text I
understand that it's literally like a
advertisement for like a class it's like
a flyer you would put up on the cork
board at a library but like that's it's
not really YouTube best practices
uh I think that sometimes in the past
here there's more like that too many
words we don't need the watercolor
classroom with your name
um all these extra texts like the most
recent ones which it would seem that
perhaps
being in part inside of video record
Academy and whatnot they seem to be the
most modern crispy clear and so keep
that going and
um this is a very inspiring Channel I
hope some of these tips added
some value all right we're in the home
stretch I'm excited for this channel Rob
um this is De Luna
and she has a harp Channel
nice I don't think I've ever audited a
hot channel in five years and 6 000
channels
as we talk about production value
[Music]
one
video wise I am inspired like I want to
be in this situation right now like I am
being transported where do you live
because I'm coming over number one
number two will you play where I can
just lay out on like a yoga mat and just
listen three
for the fact that this is
music and audio
it appears to me that we only have left
Channel
I am only getting less Channel audio
right now
have you noticed that Rob uh it's coming
through both of mine but I don't know if
not stream yards just outputting mono to
both my ah it could be mono so I don't
know if that's what other people are
hearing But ultimately
um
just a thoughtful thing that perhaps
there's some shotgun microphones that if
you don't use a converter will only give
you one channel
and this one's both so it might have
just been that video I'm getting right
and left here
beautiful
man I just am so I I love I I think
she's thoughtful to get how she got
dressed for this where she's filming the
shot composition
um very cool let's hit another one
what's this maybe some of her music with
some b-roll
perhaps she has some albums
[Music]
so this may have been recorded in um
maybe more of a studio because the
production seems a little higher and
then she put
put that on uh on there and then let's
see
we are we do have some shorts
we have got a popular song Elvis makes
sense Can't Help Falling in Love most
viewed
[Music]
looks like she probably gets hired
because she looks at some public place
where maybe they have her there playing
or that's a green screen I can't tell
about the dimension is she really there
I don't know I think so yeah there's
some random person walking in and out of
shot in the background yeah cool
um okay and uh let's see we've got 23
000 views a spike recently he's got 97
videos uploaded
the Luna is on the grind like this is a
rise and grind the Luna Harps and I'm
wondering that's probably quite a few
shorts I mean one day two days two days
three days three days three days respect
um and then quite a few shorts I'm I'm
sure so I love that Hustle
and then um but it's also go for green
so using the way I can see this on
someone else's channel is I've got vid
icq installed and then the vid IQ Vision
tool installed and so go for green
because it green is good if you could
just keep doubling down and continually
hitting green that just means you're
growing
and uh opportunity to do a little
Community tab stuff we do have 347
videos posted though and only 350
subscribers so we have almost we're like
you have to upload a whole video to get
a subscriber it appeal appears at this
current pace so I definitely think
there's some tweaks and opportunity here
but I want to hit one more thing before
Rob drops his wisdom on us
uh she does have her website so I'm
curious to see
we can discern a little bit of the
business model here and it looks like
we've got uh coaching
so
you could do there's a 12-week journey
she's got we've got testimonials maybe
people that have learned from her or
hired her to play
you could do harp lessons
we could do CDs and downloads
so we have some music here I wonder if
this is
we have what SoundCloud
band camp where we can buy her music
I do wonder how many albums are you
selling and this starts getting into
strategy of of uh do you put on Spotify
do you help educate people about that
would it even make a dent in income
because of them out you you get there
activities for music services so it's
pretty cool she has a pretty robust
career and has moved on YouTube here to
uh get the word out and promote some
things so Rob what are you seeing can
you go back to the channel I just want
to see the titles for the videos I think
we've done enough about thumbnails I
think in previous audits to say that
thumbnails could do with a bit of work
especially with the text
but I'm just looking at the titles and
I'm thinking how can these be more
accessible to a potential audience
I'm thinking genre of music for example
is there a way to insert into your
titles
uh classic or relaxing chill out one of
those buzzwords in terms of mood
followed by harp music harp cover etc
etc and then also I'm thinking from a
um video and visual perspective it was
wonderful to um listen to the music but
just watching somebody play the harp for
four or five minutes I need something
maybe a bit more visually stimulating so
what I was thinking of Sean is maybe for
the tune they could do a bit of research
on behind how the tune was
um
was scored or like who oh is there any
interesting story about the composer and
also maybe this Creator's own personal
Journey with this song What you know
what how does it make them feel was it
difficult for them to learn how to play
you know was it played at a wedding and
did a funny story happen I'm just trying
to think of some I don't so I'm not
saying voice narration I don't want it
to disrupt the music but just like
something to see visually some text on
screen maybe just adding a bit more
Intrigue to the video itself
one other idea I have is
leveraging your music
and uh I think someone if they were
asking this
um I want to contextualize these things
because I think we can all learn
from this and Robert said you know can
you help me with keeping this in context
if you're asking you know how does this
apply to my channel titles thumbnails
strategy and then business model so
being over here is saying can you do
coaching or do you have music are you
trying to get hired for wedding special
events concerts what is kind of the
different business models or offers
because some people focus I think too
myopically just on YouTube ad Revenue
here's what I think is again fascinating
I'm guessing that
you're not selling 5 000 albums a day
I'm also guessing that
over here with these digital downloads
maybe some of these are
um I mean peaceful preparation for
surgery like this is this is 18 minutes
is it it's two songs one is eighteen one
is eighteen twenty four
uh
this is awesome
and this is gonna cost
okay name your price so it is free
and it's
or you could buy all the discography for
41.40 which is all great here's here's
what I'm after I think that a different
content format on your channel is kind
of like what you did with harp and
b-roll but if you were to say like
peaceful harp
um sleep music yeah
14 million views
yeah and we have soothing relaxation 871
000 views so learning from some of this
stuff
and taking even your your pre-existing
audio which is your what's amazing is
you're the already the musician you
already have it recorded and you own the
rights to it
so you could tap into some b-roll you
could even potentially Outsource it
you're like hey here's the music you
send somebody on five or something you
just want I want some beautiful
like what do we have here
animated photos similar to these AI
generated photos
there's some
this is pretty cool I mean we have we do
have a little bit of
another layer of kind of like light
Birds
but here's here's what we're after this
video has 3.5 million views
and so back to our
potential you know 3.5 million
for if if we're getting maybe a two
dollar CPM here at minimum then we're
talking at 3.5 million
uh two dollar CPM two thousand dollars
for every million views right so
be about seven thousand dollars
potentially earned from this video and
the range of that is probably anywhere
from five thousand to over ten thousand
from this one video in fact
and I always wonder people who listen to
this that don't have YouTube premium
because I'm like how peaceful is that
like when there's multiple ad spots like
you're in the middle of the thing and
then all of a sudden you get hit like
hurts car rental is that a you know
you're like I kind of breaks my piece
but
but realizing an eight hour and nine
minute video that there's probably ad
spots every 15 to 30 minutes
um and therefore the person who just
turns it on and leaves that on why
they're chilling at their house or
working in their garage or doing chores
these could be this video could have
generated 22 000 who knows so anyways
just thinking about the assets you
already have
the things that exist in your library
already which is all of this music and
one doesn't not that you have resistance
to this but one doesn't
um
I would say
eliminate the other like someone buying
this for one dollar they're either not
gonna find it or they also will because
they're a super fan and they don't even
find your video I think that sometimes
as creatives especially as musicians we
could benefit from
um
thinking about the 2023 opportunities of
earning money from our music which could
also include streaming platforms and
things like that
350 videos so you're talking probably 10
to 12 hours if not more of music you
could take 40 of those videos
um of the same mood and genre put them
together and you've got like a three
four hour playlist right there so you
know opportunities to repurpose the
existing content on the channel if they
haven't already done that
great great tips okay
as we land the plane smash like I picked
this one out Rob
because we have lunch to Freedom it's
here to help people make money online
but as we'll see when we watch this
first video do you enjoy reading books
today I'm about to share with you how
you can make 100 to 200 and hours with
an AI channels Yes you heard me right
you can make 100 an hour reading books
you're interested b-roll make sure you
stick with me to the end I'm going to
tell you how script clearly AI you can
start making the money right after this
if you are interested make sure to stick
with me until the end welcome to lunch
to freedom in this channel we are all
about making more money and becoming
financially free
and this can be achieved by having
multiple streams of income okay so
there's a video there's no books now we
are at uh at 1 200 subscribers
three best Apps that pay you real money
update 2021.
and tech savvy world every American is
diverting to make money through
smartphone rather than hard work well
there's kind of captions but they're
it's just like a crop in of
and it looks like
is this that remix features that pay you
real money no update 2021 I don't even
know what that is in today oh sound
effect
okay so this is kind of an attempt at a
at a faceless Channel clearly we're not
registering over here
I
how to don't want to make any
accusations but I wonder if there's some
views fast money as a team college and
high school subscribers that have been
wondering about how they can earn money
preferably through a process or a weight
that does take very long sometimes they
find themselves because also comments I
mean a thousand views is is pretty legit
if it's a very engaged thousand views
you might want to see 5 10 15 20
comments from that perhaps
three best so I wonder if this thing's
kind of getting inflated up because
there's no comments here
and I don't know if that's a legit a
thousand subscribers gained but that's
just some predictions from doing this
for a while so Rob over to you
I do want to check the name of the
channel uh is it specifically lunch to
Freedom or is it should it be launched
to freedom because I see a rocket
presumably launching into the sky
my guess was like
like make money on your lunch break did
not be too far into it I literally
that's what I was like because I was
like it is for sure lunch but I was like
is it
you're right like it says lunch but it's
a rocket so it maybe should be launch
maybe also I'm sure launch to Freedom
was taken
probably probably
I think another thing I noticed was I
may be wrong again Sean you'd have to
show me the latest uploads have they
posted consistently in the last couple
of months oh yeah it has been four
months since it uploaded so
I guess uh the question here is what
what's happening are you um submitting
this channel because you're looking to
completely restart the channel from
scratch
and what I will say is that I think this
era of
um AI generated a voice and stock b-roll
it's going to be a radically different
place in about six months time because
the the sophistication of AAA tools
coming now I mean we've we're starting
to see
um chat gpt4 literally from prompts
doing everything like the inscripting
the filming the voiceover etc etc
without almost any human input other
than a few prompts so I can imagine AI
style content being significantly better
than what this currently is
um so I think if you are going to have a
faceless channel that uses AI to a
strong degree
learn how to prompt AI tools that's the
skill I think that all of us need to be
at least learning to some extent
um at the moment
thumbnails look as if they're from a
different Channel with every single one
they're like a brand new template with
each of them
um as you say Sean The View counts on
some of these seem healthy and
consistent but how reliable are they you
just don't know and I guess it is the
value proposition that you want to
launch people into Financial Freedom
yeah I mean how to earn passive income
how to make money online different
remote work and self-employed employed
businesses I'm gonna go out on a limb
here and actually guess that perhaps
this individual invested in
um some kind of a faceless Channel
I don't want to call him a scam but a
lot of them kind of are and sometimes
they're high paying and if if anyone's
done that successfully then great but
people make big promises and they
under deliver of of making easy riches
or easy success on YouTube and that's
why we're so adamant of like this is not
a get rich quick thing it's a hard work
thing it's a learn and level up thing
it's a gets your skills going thing
because I also wonder if even the
Creator themself and I've been we've
coached a few people like this where
they're looking for advice to like pass
along to their editor like if you
Outsource this
they're just kind of templating you just
thumbnails they're templating you AI
voices they're using the same b-roll and
they the individual themselves might not
even be behind these videos they might
not be architecting these videos and the
problem again with these
faceless Cash Cow Channel offers too is
you know you're just one of many and and
it's kind of a law of diminishing
returns
in terms of with content such low
quality whether that's just the AI Voice
or just kind of basic information
where I would take it to a different
direction is if we kept going down this
route is I would get heavily involved
like
you don't necessarily have to edit
yourself but if you bring in even if
you're using AI editing like I used um
video.ai the other day it's a cool tool
that'll help you do vertical video
and
it
watches one of my YouTube videos and it
pulls out some vertical video clips if I
just clicked export though it was not
very good I I trimmed the front I
trimmed the back I changed the template
I moved the captions I created a
headline I uh extended the end a little
bit the first three weren't that great
the fourth and fifth one was great
exported that uploaded it natively I
want to encourage you
whether this applies to this Channel or
not you're watching this don't take
shortcuts
um I was thinking about this this
morning even if you're a business owner
entrepreneur minded and you want to do a
channel like this where you're like I
want to hire somebody I'll hire an
editor thumbnails from Fiverr I'll do
all the things I want to challenge you
get your hands dirty roll your sleeves
up and get into the actual weeds and
education of YouTube best practices
first because
Even If eventually you you delegate
things you want to know even what
standard to hold people to the
difference between one Fiverr thumbnail
editor and another one the difference
between AI voices I would never accept
if someone submitted this video to me I
would say the voice is there's better AI
voices out there give me another one and
it's just a guess but I my thought is
they probably were paying per video
um maybe they paid somebody a bunch of
money to like set up a faceless channel
for them and then they were paying per
video and it might have been 25 a video
this is common making money is an
important part of our brand and then the
promise is we'll just keep going keep
going keep going and like even this uh
number three of ours just kind of I mean
the audio some of the b-roll is good
but yeah and so they might have grown
tired or ran out of money and that's
just one prediction of of how this
happened I don't my guess is the
individual themselves was not editing
picking out the AI and if that if they
were the same advice applies
there are better AI voice tools
the editing could be another level so if
you stick with this it's it's taking it
up to a another level of I actually
think the model can work it's just a
matter of
not being at the lowest level of quality
but going to the highest level of
quality the best AI voices the best
music good music from epidemic sound and
not the YouTube music library like all
these little details sound effects
editing pacing
so when somebody just gives you a
boilerplate video that doesn't have good
pacing the music's too loud the AI
sounds kind of robotic the script's kind
of average there's a bunch of fluff
words in it it comes straight out of
chat GPT and and there's fluff in it and
it hasn't been perfected or Polished by
a human that is going to lose to the
person who just did the six things I
described and actually enhance those
tweaks and so the need of Skilling up is
a big deal and then Shelton asks what
are your thoughts on having a mix of
faceless content where you are filming
yourself as well I think that also is
one of the models I mean kind of reminds
me of Evan Carmichael
um you know he's heavily motivation
using clips of Oprah and Elon Musk and
Jeff Bezos but he's the host I think
that
uh you know one of the things we've been
teaching in in VRA is OPC other people's
content under a fair use where you still
Evan Carmichael's a good example of that
he's using
um you know other people's content but
he's making something heavily new and
he's the host I think that
um they they say these days that AI is
not going to replace humans but a human
using AI is going to replace you if you
don't use Ai and so ultimately
um
uh a human it's it's kind of like
there's this movie called universal
Soldier
with uh Jean-Claude Van Damme there's
probably other examples plastic is that
one wow and this is this is
what the future looks like I don't know
if the analogy makes sense but yeah this
right here is the future of content
creation a human enhanced by AI
and so it's it's throwback Tuesday today
uh but but who who's gonna win versus
the universal Soldier somebody that is
human but they got the bio enhancements
uh the AI enhancements and so
I don't know if that makes sense Rob
what do you think about that analysis
Jean Claude Van Damme does not have 200
million subscribers by this time next
year Sean you can have a lot to answer
for I watched a um video from Casey
neistat today and he let
um chat GPT script his uh video and it
was funny in that it was kind it kind of
had some Casey motifs like using a um
hoverboard going to famous places in New
York doing drone shots but it was so
wooden and awkward and I think Casey
someday require the end that currently
AI lacks Soul so you can just take the
prompts of AI and let it do all of her
work it still requires a human
experience and passion and
I guess wisdom and knowledge and
vulnerability you know and the almost
like the
you know the rough edges that still
needs to be put into any AI curated
content uh but yeah universal Soldier
big throwback I do remember that one I
will say it is funny people are saying
like I never saw it now I'm interested I
can't guarantee that it's that great of
a movie it's not necessarily the first
one is the the sequels are a little
question yeah I do I I would I've been
talking I don't know what I'm on I'm on
some Nostalgia I posted about Howard the
Duck yesterday my wife's gonna find me
watching Howard the Duck universal
Soldier she has zero interest in these
things but by my point I think that
Dolph Lundgren lacks Soul too because
these guys did not really have when the
universe when the AI see that this is
actually a good point Jean-Claude Van
Damme is the perfect example
of
because he started to get his soul back
I think that that is the key Rob is he
started to fight against
the AI and so you don't want the AI to
take over to make you soulless you want
to be you want to have that you want to
stay human but use the AI to enhance
your content creation so I I don't know
if we're talking about YouTube anymore
Sean but I love it I love it
people are we've gotten a massive
throwback today uh I must break you I
think was was that um Dolph Lundgren
said that I think Howard the Duck shout
out
smash like if you're here for the
throwback movies
um hey today's stream brought to you by
good IQ Rob what are you guys doing at
vid IQ how can people connect with you
what what is vid IQ
and where are you what are you guys
doing on YouTube well ensuite at vid IQ
uh these days uh we are very much uh
like Sean and think media uh a YouTube
channel and uh software that just wants
to help you take your channel to the
next phase of your YouTube Journey
wherever you are on that Journey
YouTube
enabled me to turn my passionate hobby
into a life-sustaining
[Music]
career defining life change and I want
to try and enable that for as many
creators as possible and you can see
that through the videos I make on a very
regular basis on the vid IQ Channel but
not only are we offering all of these uh
free videos for you to enjoy but we also
have our tools that are now being
radically enhanced by Jean-Claude Van
Damme and Dolph Lundgren in our AI tools
um I'm going to be pushing for those
image rights to be added to our tools
tomorrow so um yes stick around for that
but you saw one of our tools today the
generate tool which you type in a couple
of words and it'll give you a title a
script template thumbnails scripts
etc etc but then if you dig into the
tools we've got the title generator the
daily ideas I think you mentioned that
earlier on as well Sean and yeah in a
new age of AI tools I mean we're excited
today but just imagine where vid IQ is
going to be with its tools tomorrow and
yeah as you see the 30-day trial we've
just one dollar I think that's 98 off so
do take advantage of it
yes and so always grateful for Rob drop
and massive wisdom remember we are
action takers here in the think media
podcast community and so I'm curious
what are you gonna do next I'm gonna put
a couple comments up on screen smash
like if you got value today
um watch the replay of course we're
reviewing different channels
um but there's so many nuggets that you
could say how does this apply to my
channel how can I improve my titles my
thumbnails the messaging of my channel
we talked a lot about business models
strategy earning income a lot of
different things and so uh hey Daniel
said vid IQ helped me get about 300
increase in subscribers last month
awesome report Daniel and so if you want
to check out of course that 30-day trial
too and you're watching this you could
get into the paid plan for just a dollar
at vidiq.com forward slash think and
start growing your Channel today Sheila
says I would love to know what I need to
do to improve my videos check out the
replay uh that would would be my biggest
thing Robert just says yes I want to
take action simply smoothie said do the
voiceovers and definitely watching the
replay amazing yep voiceovers I think
would be great narrating through you're
making great content congrats on all
your success with those shorts
um and uh vid IQ is a huge help on the
back end of YouTube amazing amazing so
hey uh think media podcast subscribe if
you're not subscribed smash like if you
got value today and uh we are doing a
free live training later I'm gonna rest
up I'm gonna have some more q a I'm
gonna be jumping on with Melissa talking
about how one video generated over
nineteen thousand dollars I'm breaking
down the whole case study to show you
all the economics and everything so uh
check that out I don't know what the
link is but find it somewhere and uh
maybe Victoria or somebody here will
drop that in the comments but that's
gonna be fun a little bit later
and then click or tap the screen if you
haven't seen the latest episode of the
think media podcast every Tuesday we
drop a new episode of the think media
podcast it's out on audio but it's also
available of course right here on
YouTube on the think media podcast
Channel sending you love and respect
today grateful for you
rise and grind peace out